this morning on our saturday session the
black keys the multi-grammy winning band
celebrated a milestone anniversary this
year and starting today are touring
their 11th studio album anthony mason
who has covered dan auerbach and patrick
carney's careers closely over the past
decade visited the black keys once again
in nashville at east side bowl before
they hit the road
[Music]
in the video for their latest hit single
wild child the black keys go back to
class
basically what inspired the video was
our high school
an hour back and patrick kearney both
went to harvey firestone high in akron
ohio you know our high school was
different when we we've ended up on the
hall of fame
you were there when i had when we got
put up there
if you look closely there's a nail up
there in the bricks i'm terrified of
heights then you can hand him the
picture yeah
in 2012 we watched our back climb the
trophy case to hang their photograph
it's official
that was 10 years ago that we did that
just after the breakout success of their
grammy-winning albums
brothers and el camino
[Music]
carne and our back have been the black
keys for 20 years now
[Music]
does that freak you out a little bit
but
it's been really good 20 years but it
wasn't always so glamorous for much of
their first decade they toured in a ford
van we put like
three or four hundred thousand miles on
that car wow it was insane but you're
not in that man anymore
hell no
i couldn't be i think about it sometimes
you know i mean we were driving like
10 11 12 hours every day yeah and like
sleeping in the van it was nonsense
we had our friend jeff build a loft in
the back so we could like flying down
the highway 70 miles an hour just like
this close to the ceiling
dude that was like driving around in a
casket dude it was insane
it was basically like laying in a cannon
being like waiting to get shot out
what happens if you hit a bump in the
road did you hit the ceiling yeah your
face smashes into this and you have to
go with your head to the back you had to
put your head to the back because that's
safer
yeah if it rolls over you know you only
have like 3 000 pounds of gear
loosely packed in gear
[Music]
this summer the black keys headlined
their first amphitheater tour behind
their two latest albums delta cream and
dropout boogie
before parting in nashville we played a
quick round of bumper ball
i'm hooking this makes me want to order
nachos
watch the backswing despite some wayward
caroms
oh nothing nothing no i went right and i
blew it oh my god power back now 43 and
carney who's 42 say they've found their
groove again
we communicate more now than we did even
when we were 22. so what's happened
turned into old farts
we've only got each other to talk to him
we might as well get back in the van do
you think age has something to do with
it absolutely i mean i think that
especially with the 20th anniversary
it's kind of made us put some things
into perspective i'm always reminded
when i get with pat how easy it is it's
just like
we just make music and don't even talk
about it you know and it's just a
magical
gift that we were given